[Music]
[Music]
the third lecture of our fall lecture
series God and computers Minds machines
and metaphysics I first like always
would like to thank our sponsors I
specifically would like to mention the
electrical engineering and computer
science department at MIT and also the
Sir John Templeton Foundation and the
rest of our of our sponsors you can find
on the websites and I put them this time
on both sides so if you want to visit
the websites you will find the abstracts
of the past talks and future talks and
also some links in the first lecture of
the series we heard Paul Penfield the
head of the electrical engineering
computer science department here at MIT
talking about the character of
scientific theories he expressed his
personal opinion that since that science
would not be completely sufficient to
describe what he called the human factor
his examples were love and grief and
other things last week this very human
factor was described by Mark Houser from
Harvard from a comparative pathology
perspective so he said that animals
particularly monkeys and apes share
several of these human factors with
humans like South awareness or the
notion of belief and they also can
develop rituals however he said that
they lack the notion of moral agency
today now we will hear about another
aspect of the human factor from a
psychiatric perspective and I'm very
pleased and very honored to welcome
professor means Wong here today
professor Wong is currently head of the
Harvard Medical School Department of
Psychiatry at the Massachusetts mental
health center and he is also director of
the Harvard Institute of psychiatric
epidemiology and genetics
he's internationally known
for his research on schizophrenia and
also other mental disorders
he holds an MD a PhD and a doctorate of
Science and several honorary degrees and
beside numerous awards and honors he's
member of the National Academy of
Science member of the Acadia Seneca of
Taiwan and he also just received the
Lifetime Achievement Award from the
International Society of psychiatric
genetics among his interests is
spirituality with its effects on mental
disorders and I'm really really glad
that you are now here to share with us
your ideas on brain mind and
spirituality welcome it is all now and
thank you very much for inviting me here
today I'm going to discuss with you
brain and mind and spirituality I'd like
to start off with the brain and then the
brain function and the mind and then go
into how to tackle the spirituality from
the epidemiological point of view so
let's start with the first slide can you
can you see that from there it's the
mind and the brain essentially to
understand the mental process that
essentially have changed dramatically
throughout the human history the heart
liver and other organs were believed
with the key to mental functions
particularly from a Chinese traditional
medicine still consider a liver and
kidney and the other sexual organ seems
to be trained important role in the
mental function and physical functions
and let us talk about the age in
Greeks concept all living things drew
vitality from nuuma essentially air
derived from the cosmos and then so this
related to a Chinese at Ichi and the
various kind of in and young and growth
movement and thought were caused by
alteration in this a cosmos Numa and the
river essentially is the natural spirit
heart is considered with vital spirit
and brain animal spirit or participated
this is the ancient Greeks our concept
and the modern scientific view from
sixteen and seventeen century the
concept of nervous system being
developed and essentially brain and
spinal cord being considered as a
central to the function of the nervous
system and peripheral nervous system is
essentially nervous nerves throughout
the body which said archery essentially
under the direction of central nervous
system so Center is in the brain and so
just to give you for those who I know
there are several eminent
neuroscientists here forgive me in
giving the elementary of brain structure
for those who have not seen the a brain
unlike some of the neuroscientists
dealing with this every day so
essentially this is the brain and we
have a cranial bone which protects us
and you have a juror and arachnoid and
Pia mothers if you have a concussion you
may have a breathing inside of the
bureau under dura mater subdural
hematoma and various kind of condition
and the cellulose from food ECC just to
give you our brain and the brain
somehow has the very important
demarcation for anatomists and the
neurophysiologist and the neuro chemist
to really point which path to study so
the frontal lobe I thank you and to have
this for me
so frontal lobe is here and then the
prefrontal these are and the promoter
codex so this is very important I'm
going to elaborate the mind mental
function and the brain and that this is
the marking called ruthian official and
under which is temporal lobe and the
parietal lobe and sensory cortex is here
and here is ad imitation is called
central circus and occipital lobe and in
what way this is related to our mineral
function the major external brain
structure as I show you frontal lobe is
the executive function doing things
thinking about the things and the
planning for the future and temporal
lobe is the auditory processing and
related to language of course you see
the frontal lobe also involved in
language and pride are law this is the
summary of what we know touch and
balance and occipital lobe in the back
is related to vision and brain stem is
the inducing the sleep arousal heart
rate and breathing breathing breathing
so these are the essentially the brain
structure and the functions so let us
see from the this side the frontal lobe
then pride oh no as I talked about and
the temporal lobe occipital lobe in the
back and the brainstem this is the vital
organs vital very vital to our survival
so even without this part this is the
unhurt
still we can survive and
respiration heart rate are controlled by
this area and cerebellum is related to
balance and the movement so in additions
to from outside which you can see for us
to discuss the brain function and the
mind we need to know the major internal
brain structure so hypothalamus
this is related to our thirst hunger and
sexual function cerebellum is the
balance and movement and corpus callosum
connects the two cerebral hemispheres
and psalms is important a relay station
for sensory processing read a so in this
sense you can see already here the
inside as I already talked about Copas a
column which is connect the two sides of
the brain we have a left side and right
side and these two are very symmetrical
one side can really function we know
from some of the patients even losing
one size you can survive and so this is
the copis curve then I talk about hypo
usamos and this is the pituitary gram
and then the pineal gland and thermos is
here Thomas and the Vanara this is the
brainstem midbrain pons and cerebellum
so this is just give you some of the
brain structure and the another
important thing in mental function from
psychiatric point of view is the emotion
how you feel and the the limbic system
control emotion and memory and also all
factions and this is the limbic system
inside so hyper Sammis olfactory well
tract are connected to this and
mammillary bodies in some dementia due
to alcoholism mama levels tend to have a
bleeding and amygdala and hippocampus
and phonics and some
this is actually consistent of the
important structure for our emotion and
the various important function of mine
and then there are various nucleus
within the brain and this is the caudate
nucleus and determine coded and the
Globus pallidus substantia [ __ ] this is
related to Parkinson's and so on and the
reason I show this is that in the past
we thought that this has nothing to do
with the mental function but now we know
these are also related very specifically
with a skiddo near research which we are
doing so I just I'd like to introduce
very quickly the anatomical structure
for us to understand what I'm going to
talk about so this is on the anatomical
level but within the brain there are
many many ourselves oh we call a new
room
a neuron have the nucleus and action and
with marine seas cover with the action
and then are connected with synapse to
another neuron so neuron has the action
and also have a dendrite to connect one
cell to connect to another is actually
very important so this is the two
neurons in synaptic contact and this
neural network is the as I show you is
the signal transmission from one neuron
to another and the it's been done
electrochemical and so a nerve cell
fires then signals go to the next neuron
and small white node our synapses gap
between cell in the case of multiple
sclerosis those are the one which I show
you did this
miron sees be enough
so that it sort of say the electricity
is not efficiently taslim so there is
the movement a disorder so this is the
very important function of the mind in
order for tool to connect and now I'd
like to talk about the brain development
our human being is unique and I'd like
to show you the brain development how it
develops to help you now with the mature
brain brain diverse beginning in the
first months in utero and neurons
migrate to genetically reach a
pre-planned regions which is very
important as cell migrate from the
bottom to the top to the cortex the
maximum neural migration at the middle
are three münster so if a neuron the
migration may be affected as the second
or first remonster by virus or
malnutrition or trauma it may affect the
brain cells the configuration that is
the what I am going to talk to you about
the current theory of neuro
developmental Oh mal function of the
brain are giving to schizophrenia am i
standing here can you can you see it if
I go there they cannot see so there's no
no way to so I should stand here okay
neuro migration this now become very
important schizophrenia once upon a time
thought as the position by devil at that
time we didn't know so ascribe
everything to those a superstition but
now with the new development in
neuroscience we now know that neural
migration is very important neuron
migrate in a highly organized fashion is
the pre-plan but as I say virus genetic
a malformation may affect this the
neural migration the earliest migrants
from initial deep layer data arrival
assumed places closer to the cortical
surface so just the illustrate to you
those are the the super ventricular or
ventricular cells migrate to the top in
the cortical operate where our thinking
feeling and everything is a very
important executive function so my great
migration and the earlier ones stopped
here but the data one come to the top
and sometimes there is the order to ask
some of those all the one to die in
order to say the younger one to go to
the tip to the top so it's very
interesting the brain is wiring in the
sense so so all the cells the new one
actually come to the top layers and so
this development differentiate us from
other type of creatures this development
poor mccrane represent the brain in
evolutional term from the Tyrian brain
stem survival respiration heart rate and
the mammalian limbic with the emotional
system and the nom de uma marion
actually cortex for a cognition so just
to give you some illustration is the
this is the reptilian and this is the
limbic system and then now my marion
this is the us representing the greater
area of the cortex and the cell all
migrate to the cortex and there you can
see the well arranged and well connected
from one neuron to another for the
function
so the important area which been
discovered by brokers
is the Broca's area named after poor
brokers French neurologists of the 19th
centuries and it's essentially our
speech Center is at the left inferior
frontal lobe an essential for linguistic
of fluency and if you have a stroke then
if this area is affected on the left
side if you are right hand side a person
left side effected then you have aphasia
you cannot speak so this is the Broca's
area this area and so in terms of the
mind brain and the mind brain well
integrated and so that we can do
whatever you like to do in terms of
thinking in terms of feeling in terms of
your behavior is totally integrated with
the brain and the spinal cord and
peripheral nervous system and the what
we recently found was that in Slovenia
which was originally considered to be a
possessed by the devil so you can hear
the voices which is devil voices you
believe someone is going to harm you and
that kind of abnormal behavior was
thought of as the aberration because of
the position by the a double but the
recently with the neuroscience
development we know that I'm going to
show you with the a Pettis test scanning
I show you that the the normal brain is
on the left and the brain of the person
with Socrates on the right the
schizophrenic brain demonstrated lower
blood flow we can test the blood flow in
the frontal lobe so essentially you can
see that the normal and the abnormal you
can see the blood flow is different
because the cell configuration is
different so the another one I'm showing
you normal brain on top schizophrenic
brain in the middle then we
the drug treatment alter brain function
in Slovenia so this also we can now see
from the pest scanner normal and the
skill Aranea and after application of
neuroleptics which treat the symptom of
schizophrenia and this now we can show
from PET scanners so essentially to give
you a summary in psychiatry when we
examine the mental function these are
the three cardinal aspects we call
mental status we examine and to
characterize what is the function of the
mind mind cannot be seen but as a
psychiatrist we see the mind when mind
is functioning and three-dimensional
approach to the mind mental function is
the you think you feel and you behave
and these three all of us are well
integrated so when you you think you you
think about the happy events you're
feeling feel high and you become sort of
a elated and restless so these are the
Congress function however in the case of
Mania is hyperfunction you have a lots
of ideas and you feel that you are so
great you become the president of the
United States this day become the
president United States is not as good
as before but and if you you are
overactive so that is the mania and the
depression is the hyper function of
these three so however these three
function our Congress instead of Lynnea
this is just for illustration in
schizophrenia these three function of
mine something happened here and current
the theory is the brain function are
disturbed so the when you believe that
people trying to harm you yet your
expression is opposite
not fearful and then you are supposed to
run run because someone is trying to
harm you but this person sit there still
so this is the concept of schizophrenia
different from mania and depression so
this is the so a study during the last
30 years our group are trying to find
what are the potential risk factors
affecting the brain for this three
function to become in Congress so
essentially what I'm saying is that
schizophrenia is no longer the myth is
the brain disorder and we are now trying
to tackle what are the genetic
components of it what are the
environmental component particular
intrauterine or condition and after
birth in what way the environment
actually interact with the congenital
malformation so our group in
collaboration with the mass journal of
neural imaging we shown that this is a
normal a control of the normal person
volunteer in the case of snoring
patients lateral ventricle the other
event will become bigger an inferior
lateral ventricle a bigger because the
brain shrink essentially the cortex and
other area of the brain volume decreased
so the the relevant ago we're supposed
to have a cerebrospinal fluid occupy
there is more so this is the indication
of the brain becomes smaller and not
only that sons or bladder bendigo is
actually wider and the thermals which i
already shown to you Taman paradin
hippocampus amygdala complex this is all
related to feeding and
Oshin smaller than normal control now
the research which we are doing is this
the not only we are studying
schizophrenia patients only we are now
studying the relatives of schizophrenia
where we are doing the collection of DNA
and to test the genes but capitalize on
that opportunity we compare the
relatives who are not schizophrenia yet
still they show a differences comparing
with normal essentially I show you this
other area which been affected even in
the relatives so it means that in the
past we don't know who to intervene to
prevent the onset of schizophrenia now
we know the earlier treatment the better
and even better is before the treatment
if we can find cognitive deficit and the
neuroimaging abnormalities we may be
able to prevent them so this is the our
work so in addition to that we use a
functional MRI the control comparing
with relatives of Cochran and across the
Slovenia is like this but this is the
mind essentially for the normal you
don't need to use so much energy to do
the assigned tasks in Slovenia and the
relatives because their brain cell is
around in such an inefficient way they
have to utilize so much brain areas to
perform the same function same function
at the controls so current are very
strong hypothesis and with scientific
evidence is the neuro developmental
models this proposed that the some
combination of genetic and non-genetic
errors
these two mile development of the brain
in childhood and we can see that
neuropsychological optimality in
children of suffering patient and the
obstetrical complication in birth of
snoring pace and all of interact to
result into a sovereign brain and
therefore brain and mind in normal it's
well integrated in schizophrenia which
is the area of our research for a long
time we feel that we can really study
brain to identify as schizophrenia and
also this is all in research it's not in
practical application yet we are trying
to find a gene for a slovenia so what we
are doing is that the National Incident
mental health support us to collect the
200 families in which two or more
affected and we interview all of the
family members and then we'll collect a
DNA and VA nationally we are collecting
another 200 and then from there we like
to study what are the potential genes we
already know there is no one gene
Forrester crania there must be many
genes to interact with the environment
to develop and not only that what we are
studying is the sub stressful Slovenia
it's costly ataxia in a poor mill term
essentially those who have not developed
schizophrenia yet but they have a
tendency to inherit a schizophrenia a
trait and using the neuropsychological
cognitive deficit an MRI family study of
Slovenia we are tackling that what is
the genotype and what is the phenotype
of a stroke linear so the current
concept is this the it's a vulnerability
with a genetically or the intra uterine
abnormalities
is a stress model and the if the stress
is the environmental risk factors is a
higher then becomes crania and the if
not is a subspace for called spectrum
disorders of this kind and genetic
predisposition so this is pretty much to
summarize the current theory of
schizophrenia we have not found one gene
for schizophrenia yet we know there are
several gene involved so essentially to
summarize current or finding a concept
of schizophrenia before I move into
spirituality is that schizophrenia from
ancient biblical teaching all considered
to be possessed by the devil but now
with a scientific approach neuroscience
we now know schizophrenia is a disorder
mainly from brain and its effect is
thinking and feeling and the behavior
and we now think our group think that
from available data there is a genetic
predisposition an early environmental
insult develop into the mouth
development of the brain particularly in
codex and here P dr. Steele matrices
here in his hospital to Macrina study
actually analyzing the brain neurons
arrangement in the cortex and find the
arrangement on each layer seems to be
are not all properly arranged in
comparing with normal so it's the
nirodha mental abnormalities and the
data environmental insult or
particularly at the addresses these are
all present but is silent and later
particularly at the teenage addresses or
period where
neurons the gross brain growth and the
external environmental insults essential
result in brain cannot react to the
demand of the environment because brain
is already abnormal and then for the
brain dysfunction and schizophrenia and
then schizophrenia causing psychosis
psychosis by that meaning the these
three function become incongruous and
then hearing voices and then can hear
owns thoughts aloud there are many many
bizarre delusions related to many things
and in the past when use use in the past
when we don't know the saturate function
some of the patient already believed at
all I can travel to other universe and
the batter now seems to be a real so
that is no longer the delusions
so delusions the definition has to be
interpreted from the cultural context so
the important part is this if
schizophrenia developed psychosis
develop it trigger the current theory it
triggered potentially become the neural
degeneration there is no evidence yet
but that we know if schizophrenic
psychosis episode developed whose
episode you don't treat then second
episode third episode then it is very
difficult to treat
so current emphasis is on how to prevent
the onset of psychosis and at the
massachusett mental health center we are
trying to develop a prevention center
and now it is not just to treat we are
trying to develop a prevention strategy
both from biological and the
environmental our point of view
so once it was a Miss now we understand
the brain and with the NIH effort called
decade of brain lots of effort have been
utilized to study the brain of
schizophrenia and affective disorders
and others so this is just to give you
some of the current study on brain and
mind now with this background we
specially we are like in the old days
spirituality is a myth and spirituality
is the superstitious or a concept a
particular enmity where they are also
reasonable also logic so she passed the
spirituality when you talk about it it
is a myth it is the superstition but
still Iranian the reason I use Slovenia
was this that in the past as crania
considered to be a myth but there is the
scientific approach of the neuroscience
we are able to tackle them now we
consider this to be treatable and if we
can clone the genes we will be able to
develop the real treatment and
prevention and so on so with this at the
basis I am now going to move into a very
difficult area of the spirituality
particularly for grey scientists here at
the MIT I'm not saying that there are no
great scientists at Harvard and because
I am just a saying that we are here at
MIT
so forgive me if you are coming from
eminence professor coming from Harvard
forgive me I because we are utilizing
MIT s space so the reason we couldn't do
screen research is that there was no
definition the Frisian is according to
professors definition professor said
this is Slovenia when it was a Dark Age
of psychiatry now we develop all kind of
criteria which we study internationally
which I participate and that we do the
long term follow-up and family studies
we already know there are essentially
good criteria for diagnosis but not
necessary for research so now we at
least have a operational definition of
schizophrenia in spirituality I was
invited to NIH to the alternative
medicines a conference and I asked say
there are many many expert there I said
could you define for me what is
spirituality apparently like a Dark Age
of Psychiatry where everyone has their
own definition of schizophrenia
nowaday we have a common criteria so it
is important to develop the criteria
before we launching into the
spirituality when you read in the
magazine and the time managing and New
York Times they are talking about if you
pray more and then your health is better
those kind of things we need to do the
rigorous research I believe we cannot do
it complete right in Slovenia we still
we did it but we only scratched the
surface and like I sort of feel that
doing research on spirituality is like
doing our skill Iranian research in the
Dark Age of Psychiatry and operational
criteria is very important to really
tackle
is spirituality related to a health ill
health mentoring or physically and from
my practice of seeing patient many
patients in the past are seldom they
talk about a spiritual dimension now if
you ask which denomination which
religion are you afraid it they will
start a talk particularly for mental
patients they'd like us to really engage
in mind brain and spiritual dimension
and if you are our patients are
interested in using the spirituality
dimension to help their illness why
should we deny them and you know that
you know that be from your own existence
even though you don't know where the
mind is but now we know it is a brain
and we know their function and because
we operationalize what is the mental
function for the spirituality research
which we are now running on we have to
have at least some of spiritual
operational definition so this is not
the definition which I'm proposing I
just give you an one example of the you
have to characterize what is Slovenia in
doing spirituality research we have to
characterize miserable a spiritual
dimension I'm not saying that with this
we can understand all the spirituality
like in Slovenia we characterize them we
understand the brain yet we still don't
know many many aspects of Slovenia but
at least that we can get to the OU some
aspects of Slovenia like this our group
now launching into the spirituality of
research and I'm going to give you some
of the spirituality research affecting
the health which we are now
contemplating to Nanshan but before that
let us how many minutes do I still have
kill me
2220 okay so this for me to organize the
this very important aspect of the
spirituality research the participation
in organized region participation in an
organized spiritual activities prayer
and meditation read sacred scriptures
prophets our relationship with God or an
out min spiritual reality prophets to
believe in in corporal spirit or soul
gives unselfish and surface Lee of your
time and resources to help others this
is a very broad definition of
spirituality so with this if we can
characterize them then we'll be able to
use a political technique to really
study them the current report are not
saying currently pota all wrong they are
tilted to a very subjective
interpretation of the result which I'm
going to emphasize so we need to
thinking about the in epidemiology
you always think in about a rate the
numerator and the denominator so this is
talking about a denominator when you
talk about the rate of those will pray
versus who do not pray you have to have
which operation I'm talking about
and then operational definition is a
numerator so here here the in various
population whether you study children
teenagers or elderly or severely
mentally ill or chronically ill or
disabled and economically disadvantaged
minorities terminal you or dying
essentially just a dua senses about the
hub you go on to church and you don't
know which kind of population are
studying you don't know the denominator
that is a problem
of the research in this area so when we
study them we need to instruct linear
there are several subtypes we subtype
them and study them then we know how to
study efficiently so the gender some of
them never report what is the sex what
is the agenda and then reporter you do
this then this happen that is all very
very erroneous approach to the study of
spirituality it is so difficult to study
then if you mix the denominators then
you are unable to study them then what
religion education social economic
status when you read a New York Times
they talk about the various kinds I'm
seldom they characterize the denominator
from which they are the population are
drawn so the and then operational
definition of this spirituality this is
very important aspect of Epidemiology
which I am specialized in mind is a
psychiatric epidemiology meaning
studying the mind and the function of
the mind then we use that technique to
see if we can operationalize
spirituality to certain extent I am NOT
saying perfect like a slope lineae we
have operational criteria and study
brain we now need to study our
spirituality using the a similar
technique and then the another deficit
is that in some of the reports which you
read they seldom have a control group
there is no comparison group then just
study them it is not going to get
anywhere so the control group to examine
possible effect this is difficult to
study but we can design it with a
comparison group to study the what is
app receiver effect so in addition to
that you say improve
what is improved there is no criteria
for outcome so it is difficult to
calculate them you need to study the
physical health and then characterize
them in heart disease cancer or
mortality mental health so I get
diagnosed substance abuse and the
help-help-help destinies hopelessness
and coping style and various kind of
suicide attempt and as more importantly
the marital status or economical status
apparently focus is not good you can you
focus a little bit it's alright the
educational outcome and arrest and
conviction okay that's fine thank you
thank you very much
so outcome has to be assessed in order
to study the spirituality and its impact
on health physical and mental health
so this assessment has to be reliable
you need to develop the assessment form
and which test and retest reliability of
the assessment and then train people to
really commerce with real assessment of
outcome and this outcome has to have
it's not just a reliable it has to have
it's a validity and has to be objective
and standardized and when you are
interviewing by comparing the control
group and the experimental group it has
to be blind when we study screener
relatives we we don't know whether what
kind of relatives are we studying this
kind of a modern epidemiological
technique has to be utilized so the
epidemiological study we tend to jump to
cause-and-effect in schizophrenia in the
beginning we thought that that there is
a cause-and-effect relationship we don't
know there is a cold one cause we know
the
risk factors using the same analogy that
if there is evidence that spirituality
is associated with improve health
outcome we want to know whether there is
a cause and effect relationship
cause-and-effect spirituality leads to
lower levels of anxiety versus
Association is spirit spirituality and
low anxiety actually intervene related
with a correlation so cause and effect
we so usually it's the published paper
or the newspaper talking about is
usually the correlation is not a
cause-and-effect and written in such a
way to mislead people to really think
that there is a cause-and-effect
relationship and then the
cause-and-effect is helpful to clarify
the concept of course traditional
concept of a necessary cause and the
traditional concept of sufficient cause
and epidemic are concept of contributory
cause those need to be applied and the
essentially in complex situation with
many contributing factors one also need
to consider supportive criteria who are
contributing all strengths and
consistency or association between
spirituality and health outcome and if
this is biologically plausible that is
important and evidence of relationship
between increased spirituality and
better health outcomes and the
interpretation of the result could not
be a subjective should be based on the
evidence and the extrapolation to new
population once you find the new finding
of the spirituality and health
relationship you need to apply to
another denominator and to see it could
be generalizable so I just give you one
example of what we have and what we are
beginning to do it is my personal
conviction
from my own practice and my own personal
belief the spiritual dimension is there
and I believe that with the rigorous
current research methodology which we
use for Slovenia we can apply to study
spirituality and its relationship with
health particularly with mental health
which is my area and I witness that the
patient one-to-one spirituality affect
the patient's very much so that again
drug abuse in a depression and so on so
we now have the huge sample of the twins
about the 4000 twins pairs and we the
conceptual model is this essentially
here we have a concordant monozygotic
twins all right and the if we develop a
speech of scale the mean score and then
this is very difficult to see because I
simplified but I used a few minutes to
ear abolish this to conclude this is
what I reported to national in stock but
drug abuse to study them essentially the
identical twins they share all the genes
in common and what become difference is
that some other factors which is non
genetics are affecting the concordance
or discordance concordance meaning that
both identical twins are non abusers
never abuse drugs never been diagnosed
as the the drug abuse then the abuser
are those both identical twins in the
pair are drug abusers and discordant
meaning that one
twin monozygotic identical twin is non
abusers and another one is abusers okay
so the inference here is that if you are
both abusers then control for genetics
make up the mean score of speciality
hyper hypothesis which I would like to
test should be the lowest and the
concordant one in the middle then
discordant a twin who share the same
genetic makeup yet this person is non
abusers and this person says
spirituality score is high so
essentially spirituality is a protective
factor abusers should score relatively
low on spirituality non abusing members
appears concordance for non abuse that
is ro this subject have speakers called
intermediate between abusers and non
abusers from discordant pairs because
none abusers from discordant pair which
have a high spirituality scores are
assumed to be at high risk for relaxed
abuse the absence of abuse suggests the
presence of a protective spiritually
factor this is I'm just talking about
the one way of approaching them then
another dimension of the spirituality
which temperance foundation is very
interested is the how to tie the
spirituality dimension of a thankfulness
and forgiveness to relate it to physical
health and the mental health so we now
are corrected twins who are served in
the Vietnam veteran Vietnam veterans
served in the Vietnam as the other
combat Sierra and some of them identical
twin both are there some of them both
are in the continental United States
the total of a whole southern pairs we
can study the post traumatic disorders
post-traumatic stress the soil in the
combat you see a friend died and that
you see and why some of them are still
thankful and why some them of the inner
bitter and we can control for the
environment and the genetic makeup to
study them so in a nutshell what I'm
saying is this it is difficult to study
spirituality and I have to confess that
the we cannot understand spirituality
fully but that spirituality is there and
if we think that we are just a brain and
mind you are under estimating yourself
there is a spiritual dimension laughs
and the thankfulness forgiveness those
are considered to be very important
vital part of spirituality so dicus or
any research if we can tie this together
and at least from epidemiological risk
factors design will be able to
characterize them then later is not a
dream now with the neuroimaging with the
brain abnormality which we can
characterize them we may be able to find
at that source area I'm dreaming those
area which actually expresses
thankfulness or forgiveness in a like a
vietnam-era being killed friend being
killed by a Vietnamese and still now can
forgive those kind of tendency is
actually very much about genetics and
environmental interaction we now know
that the you may not have believed it
the data if you characterize whales
spirituality has the familial and the
genetic of tennessee's but not all
genetics shared environment is also very
important so in conclusion what I am
saying is that doing schizophrenia for
the last 35 years
I personally convinced that a
spirituality which is my personal belief
with the existence of this spirituality
I really like to tackle this very
difficult or subject do it properly and
then we'll be able to understand the
mind brain and spirituality and my time
is up thank you very much
thank you so much any questions we can
develop there are already many scales
for spirituality then you rate each each
twins then you take that the mean is
common score and there are many scores
and we are trying to develop our own to
suit our own study population yes
form of a structural defect in the brain
yeah at the same time that I guess it's
known I think that usually on teenage
you also said that it comes in episode
so it's a structural defect why does it
have this specific onset and this has
been a very very important question why
having this mouth development already
there at the verse and why you do not
have a onset a very early and usually
occur from age 15-16 that is a teenage
period the current theory is this that
the brain development has not mature yet
until the teenage and when in the
addressing period our demand from the
invar brains the demand from the
environment become
heavier and heavier and at that time all
the maturity of the brain actually
accomplished at that time instead of
linear brain it has not been
accomplished that much immature brain
cannot cope with the environmental
stress so usually that is a time because
the brain is so inefficient then to
respond to the environment it cannot
function therefore develop the symptoms
that is a current theory when you don't
treat a psychosis psychosis may become
the trigger in effect for the another
episode so need to be treated so our
current approaches to how to find those
children who have not developed
schizophrenia yet yet we know there is a
genetic risk factors and environmental
risk factors with a brain imaging
abnormality how to help them not become
instead of raining so Lauren research is
now moving into prevention mode it is a
it's a cutting-edge research not in
everywhere yes
so
and how do you think the role of Piper
plays specifically it wore my opinion
forgiveness Edith Agnes yes and a lot of
examples a lot of illustrations he come
up in the Bible how important do you
think the Bible plays intro yes is the
description of the spirituality all the
parable all the example which been shown
is to show the existence of soul and
that is part of the our spiritual
dimension that is the Bible is the
document of the spiritual manifestation
of the human behavior and also a gas or
interaction with human being so I hope I
that answer your questions I may need to
take another one hour to deal with your
questions
you bypass the question about the the
neural neuro physiological basis of
Independence of neuroanatomy and
spirituality by saying we can't really
deal with that however if we can find a
correlation spirituality and mouth and
find a neurological subs great forth
that's good enough then if we can write
a six or a Nia we are doing new neural
imaging of brain it is not good enough
we'd like to go into prevention mode and
then we are trying to find where if we
use the particular drugs which part of
the brain is effective and when we are
doing psychotherapy the patients say you
are you are your statement doctor what
you tell me
I feel so released with my burden and in
the future
when you are doing psychotherapy you may
be able to do PET scanner or functional
MRI to show which brain areas affected
so what I am trying to do if we really
find that thankfulness and the
forgiveness is actually related to
mental health I'd like to see when one
feels thankful one field to be able to
forgive which part of the brain is
actually related then we'll be able to
really do something so this is a first
step and for some research I have been
involved for thirty years and the only
accomplished a little bit the
spirituality I don't think it is going
to be easier than schizophrenia but
inside all all of us acknowledge we have
the speech outside of us depending on
how you define them okay is that okay
yeah sure we have we have five more
minutes
that's justjust for other people who
weren't here last week we heard last
week a lot about consciousness so
consciousness actually is the entire
brain integration but if you'd like to
tell me ask me where are the important
aspects of the consciousness in a brain
I didn't talk about is the reticular
formation in the near the brainstem and
up there are reticular formation which
is the absorbing the external stimuli
and then passed on to higher cortex and
to keep you alert and that is the total
integration of the inter brain and to be
aware of what is going on and how to tie
this with spirituality is you're a
cognitive function of you are in
communication with the supernatural and
that is also part of the you are
cognition of able to perceive able to
realize the existence with your
communication from your spiritual
dimension so if either you can say there
is no such things but from our
a'practice
and my personal experience I firmly
believe at this time that there is the
spiritual dimension which applied to my
patients and to myself and where it is
located probably related to as you say
the consciousness cognitive function but
it's also related to feeling emotion
which I talked about so we don't have an
exact location if I can get to that I'll
not be here
I have to go to Stockholm I think one
more question
yes for example Buddhist monks yeah
someone which is actually got a really
pretty MIT yeah are you aware of studies
of the sort of neurological differences
between let's say experienced meditators
and non-meditators or people might
consider behind the spiritual and others
yeah there are lots of reports but for
me to really say that is credible to
meet the criteria which I today IRA's
really so I have not come up with the a
good study which I can code so sorry I I
don't have yeah there are several
publication but if you use the
epidemiological or approach to that
those are should I say shaky-shaky
because they use a denominator and the
numerator are not in accordance with our
criteria but on the personal level one
to one I'm talking about the application
to everyone to the huge population that
is what the epidemiology study but a
person to person if you talk to a person
they firmly believe that the mind
meditation actually affect my physical
well-being and if he said that who are
you to deny that he doesn't feel that
now individually my patient tell me
after you talk to me and you say prayer
may help us you know in my first I I was
a Catholic but I never went to any a
church but now I'm depressed then I
start to pray and go be whole I feel
better
whether it's a placebo effect or not
individual case so
we have to divide the individual
dimension and the whole epidemiological
so one one
Who am I to deny this peasant a
statement of his conviction I cannot
that is important things to
differentiate unfortunately we have to
stop
[Applause]